he has no basis to do that he's just a
political hack who's trying to build a
name for himself and I think that's fine
because that's what they do
but there would be no reason to do that
no other politician has to go through
that
it's called presidential harassment and
it's unfortunate and it really does hurt
our country
president Trump blasting congressman
Adam Schiff and Democrats as they get
ready to launch sweeping investigations
beyond the Russia probe this time
they're going to look into tax returns
personal finances and business deals
from the decades before Trump's
presidential campaign the president
tweeting that Republicans never did this
to President Obama while slamming the
probe as quote a continuation of the
witch-hunt the president also declaring
quote presidential harassment it should
never be allowed to happen again
but could this aggressive approach
backfire 2020 Democrats apparently
tiptoeing around the Moller probe
according to Politico and here I'm
quoting Democrats behind for the White
House want to talk about anything right
now but Robert Muller's Russia probe but
the 2020 race is inevitably going to
keep coming back to 2016 and what the
special counsel uncovers Jesse I was
struck he says he says this is political
hack Adam Schiff he says there's no
basis for it presidential harassment
nuts a witch-hunt never happened before
I thought this comes from the guy who
did the birther stuff well at least he
got his name right what did he call him
last time Adam what no I don't want to
get here's what I think one if you want
to look at foreign financial influence
on politicians what about the Clinton
Foundation they got 25 million dollars
from the Saudis what about the million
dollar Russian dossier that tried to
influence elections I want to be fair
and balanced about it too I think white
water was probably a witch hunt also
there really wasn't much there either
but if you do look inside the Trump
Organization I'm sure you're gonna find
a little something or other look every
bank on Wall Street has paid hundreds of
million dollars of fines to regulators
every pharmaceutical company every
energy company you can always find
something there take a look at Congress
settle multi-million dollar harassment
lawsuits and in their pointing the
fingers the media companies they're
firing all their executives and talent
because of sexual misconduct paying out
class-action lawsuits everybody's got
something and if you look really deep I
just think the president is thinking to
himself this is ten years ago fifteen
years ago I didn't know I was running
for president I was trying to make money
I didn't need to run for president I
didn't need the money I sacrifice all
this because I was trying to save
America from going over the cliff I
wouldn't give him anything I wouldn't
give him the tax returns
I'd say leave it alone well the tax
returns in fact are a hot item right now
David the president has said you know
all of this is what do you say at the
State of Union a ridiculous partisan
investigation right and made the case
that really it is as he described it
harassment but I'm thinking to myself
wait a second most presidents do release
tax returns and they're going to go now
potentially in the next two to three
months they get the tax returns possibly
to see if there was Russian influence in
terms of his finances what do you think
here's my guess of the Democrats game
plan and by the way don't you think Bob
Muller and his special counsel team have
the dog on tax returns yes they do so
the Democrats have been wringing their
hands about he's gonna fire Muller that
POTUS so they have to wait now and wait
for the report or reports to come out so
what are they gonna do the plan is to
get every ounce of information on
President Trump and his family to just
embarrass him before the 2020 election
remember that up to early October New
York Times report about the the family
the family finances Trump's tax schemes
and then reaping riches from his father
that was a road map to what the
Democrats are gonna do as they wait for
the Muller report to come out because
they can't talk about impeachment
remember Nancy Pelosi said during the
midterm elections stay away from
impeachment and it did work form so Dana
what do you think do you think that the
Democrats may be getting over their skis
here yes there is always the tendency to
overreach and in this case in particular
I think when you're looking back it's
not like there isn't enough for the
government to investigate the Congress
to investigate in terms of the current
administration
raishin I mean everybody talks about
what's happening at the White House but
about ten years ago may have you heard
one thing about the Department of Energy
in the last you know two years like
where where is everybody like there's
there's nothing being done in terms of
oversight for those those departments
and agencies and that's what Congress
was set up to do under the Constitution
I also think that the Democrats must
think that Moeller investigation is not
going to be the scalp that they wish so
that's why they're like now we better
start planting seeds because it's not
going to be enough to snuff out his
reelection efforts the other thing is
the left-wing really wants this and so
you have to think about what the
Republicans are going to push back but
the Democratic 2020 candidates as
reported in Politico today they don't
want to talk about robert muller they
want to win the presidency and the
Moller investigation is not the path to
the presidency but do you think Greg
that in fact the voters when they gave
the Democrats control of the house we're
looking for a check on the president I
mean Devin Nunez when he was in charge
of house at house investigations
committee I mean he was basically
working for Trump so this is the other
side now now you have a committee that's
going to go after Trump yeah I will go
with what Dana said is she hit the nail
on the head
this is about Muller he doesn't have
anything so why are they running for
this stuff because they realize his
investigation isn't going to reap the
rewards that they want so now it's a big
letdown so now the returning it's like
reanimate er they're going back to the
dead stunts of the past and they're
trying to infuse them so like it's a tax
read now it's the tax return corpse that
they're trying to breathe new life into
because nothing else has worked the h1
should do a where are they now on all of
these scandals because they pop up
Trump's insane where did that go you
know the BuzzFeed story where did that
go how can we still don't know who was
behind the BuzzFeed thing these I have
advice for these perennial losers why
not try to win the presidential election
you got two years find a candidate the
only faith reason why I think they can't
they aren't doing that and they're doing
this is because they don't think they
can win right so if they can't beat them
they want to cheat them they're like
those players in soccer when they know
they can't win they faked an injury and
they fall
that's the only way to be Trump as they
make up a penalty and that's what's
going on but I do believe to your point
this is about them knowing that the
molar thing is is not going to give them
what they want so now they're digging
into the cemetery for dead smears and
they found the tax return and you know
what you say tax returns to anybody you
know what they do but yeah well that's
why that story you mentioned last
November this is a New York Times dad
was like eighteen thousand words it
didn't go anywhere and there everybody
the Democrats are so frustrated about
that well I think people even in the
conservative echo chamber have heard
about Mike Flynn and Paul Manafort and
people going to jail I think you've
heard about you saying this is a firm
liz'll echo chamber echo chamber